[Music]
tonight on brian ross investigates new
developments in one of America's great
criminal mysteries the disappearance of
former Teamsters Union boss Jimmy Hoffa
according to his family former Teamsters
President Jimmy Hoffa is missing family
made the missing-persons report this
morning after years of silence and long
suspected as being involved hafez
long-time right-hand man Chuckie O'Brien
now coming forward in the movies he was
played by Danny DeVito he's a key figure
in the new mob movie above the Hoffa
disappearance the Irishman starring
Robert De Niro and Al Pacino he always
charged a guy with a gun with a knife
you run away now while Brian opens up in
a new book written by Harvard Law
Professor Jack Goldsmith who it turns
out is O'Brien's stepson Goldsmith joins
us from his office in Cambridge and
we'll hear from the reporter dan moldea
who was made investigating this crime
his passion after 34 years can this
mystery ever be solved plus our shadow
for the brave reporter in Ukraine who
has doggedly pursued corruption even as
she's been taken hostage threatened with
execution and called both a hero and a
traitor
honest journalists in the best form of
patriotism from the law and crime
Network studios in New York City's
Herald Square this is Brian Ross
investigates good evening and welcome
tonight new developments and surprising
revelations about one of America's great
crime mysteries the disappearance 34
years ago a former Teamsters Union boss
Jimmy Hoffa the search for Hoffa has
often taken out a comedic feel as the FA
has dug up fields and basements across
the country looking for his body with no
results other than great embarrassment
for the FBI but there's nothing funny
about it for the hotha family and those
involved and those accused of being part
of it and tonight we're going to hear
from a harvard law professor jack
goldsmith a former top Justice
Department official who has spent years
trying to get to the bottom of it and
the name of hafez right-hand man Chuckie
O'Brien who was long considered by the
FBI to be a key suspect what was not
widely known about the professor until
now is that O'Brien was the professor's
stepfather
my father James our father has been
missing for some 32 hours the
disappearance of the former teamster
boss Jimmy Hoffa made headlines around
the world
former Teamsters president Jimmy Hoffa
is missing what happened to labor leader
Jimmy Hoffa a hero to his union members
law enforcement saw Hoffa as a corrupt
tyrant who was in bed with the Mafia
which then wanted him out of the way
when he blocked their access to hundreds
of millions of dollars in the union's
pension stocks within days of his
disappearance
the FBI concluded that Chuckie O'Brien
had played a key role in luring Hoffa to
his killer in the movie Hoffa O'Brien
was played by Danny DeVito his hafez
right-hand man like an adopted son but
someone who then betrayed the union boss
[Music]
the FBI continued his focus on O'Brien
even as he denied any involvement
actually getting permission from mafia
leaders to go public with his denials
the FBI came to believe that O'Brien
picked up office and a car belonging to
a Detroit Mafia figure something Brian
denied strongly saying blood stains in
the back belong to a fish that he had
picked up mr. Hoffa was never in that
car and I'll tell the world that they
can take that car apart they can do what
they want to do with it the truth is
they know that there was a salmon in the
back of that car not mr. Hoffa the FBI
watched in amazement as O'Brian showed
up on the Maury Povich Show and took a
lie-detector test about his involvement
which Povich said he had passed did
Chuckie O'Brien passed the lie detector
test yes sir the day pass O'Brian was
too emotional to even respond you passed
me yeah you're still you're still
emotional watching all this play out was
his young stepson Jack
who always believed in Chucky here's a
family photo from Christmas five months
after Hoffa disappeared Chucky and Jack
when Jack was a student at the Florida
Air Academy here's a photo from Jack's
graduation from Washington and Lee
University and now after years of
research Jack is up with his book in
hafez shadow a stepfather a
disappearance in Detroit and my search
for the truth and we are joined now by
Professor Jack Goldsmith the author of
this new book Inhofe the shadow and the
stepson of Chuckie O'Brien professor
gunsmith Jack when you first told me
that you a distinguished professor and
former senior Justice Department lawyer
in the bush administration that you were
Chuckie O'Brien stepson I was frankly
stunned as a reporter at NBC News years
ago I covered the Teamsters and the
Hoffa disappearance your stepfather was
described to me then by the FBI as a
mafia hoodlum who helped the mob rip off
the Union as someone the FBI seemed
convinced had helped the mob get rid of
Hoffa but now reading your book an
excellent book so good so intriguing
I've come away with a much different
picture tell me about the relationship
between you and Chucky how is he doing
now
he's actually not doing very well Brian
I'm sorry to report he is he's very much
under the weather and he's suffering
from severe diabetes and some other
problem he's still with us but he's not
doing great I'm afraid in the book he
opens up about some aspects of this and
insist that he was not the person who
lured Jimmy Hoffa to his killers you
believe that you believe there's
evidence that you've clearly shown that
I do believe that I mean he's been
saying that he's been denying his
involvement since 1975 but he didn't
have the time or the resources reflected
the skills to try to get to the bottom
of the charges against them and the
holes in the target against and I do
believe that I have established and
everyone's read the book that I spoken
to him anyway thinks that I established
that he did not in fact picked up off of
that day as he's been accused of doing
and you believe the FBI knows who killed
kaufe who killed Hoffa I do believe it
part of them one of the many reasons I
believe that he's innocent in addition
to all of the evidence that I gather in
the book is that the Federal Bureau of
Investigation has
believed that he was involved in the
Hoffa disappearance since the 1990s and
one of the many reasons they came to
that position there were lots of reasons
for it but one of the many reasons they
came to that belief is that they in the
interim and this hasn't been recorded
they in the interim developed a
different theory and they think they
know who was involved in actually
picking up Hoffman hand and killing him
although I haven't seen yet their
evidence that oh I know that they have
that belief question for you from our
control room from the executive producer
Rhonda Schwarz Rhonda Jack in this
fascinating book you write that the FBI
is never officially cleared Chucky even
though he's answered all the questions
you were an official at the top levels
of the Justice Department does this make
you lose faith in the integrity of the
DOJ the system I haven't lost faith in
system department justice but they did
not treat myself father well they
promised him they reached out to him
they asked them to come forward for
interviews they told him if he told the
truth that they would exonerate him
because they believed that he was not
involved he spoke to them in not great
shape for four hours at his legal peril
he answered every question they
acknowledged that he answered every
question truthfully and then they never
came through with the promised
exoneration Chuck one of the things you
will reveal in the book or talk about is
the fact that there was a hair
discovered in this car belonging to the
mobster that appeared to have a DNA
match with Jimmy Hoffa doesn't that
contradict your theory no it doesn't
this is one of the main pieces of
circumstantial evidence against Chuckie
that the car that he was driving that
afternoon that he acknowledged he was
driving well the FBI found a hair in it
that was later years later determined to
be a DNA match with Jimmy Hoffa there
were nine days in between the time that
the FBI picked up that car and the day
of the disappearance but the reason that
I and I should add the FBI came not to
think that that hair in the car proved
anything because as I say the other
circumstantial and other evidence
suggests he he didn't do it plus it
turned out they believe that the heart
the air the hair got there through hair
transfer through the
Bologna's organized crime members who
are talking to hop in week for the
disappearance there's evidence in the
FBI files which I quoted in my book
showing that an anthony jacqueline he
actually got on his knees and moved or
rug where hopper used to work out
and during that there would have been
hundreds of hair transfers to jack
solonian the FBI believe that's how the
hair got the part it seems completely
implausible but everything in this case
seems applause that's what they thinkin
extradite jack you grew up the
stepfather who was involved with the
mafia with Union corruption Jack Avani
the head of the Detroit mobster or one
of the top men was to you Uncle Tony
right he was he and I when I was a
teenager I really admired him I loved it
he was very kind to me at a time when my
family was in dire straits let me ask
you about this new movie coming out the
the Irishman based on the account of one
former hitman who says that he killed
Hoffa and then he claims Chuckie O'Brien
was in the car at least in his book
right what do you bill I've written I've
written a long essay about this which
can be found on the web I think that
that confession is just not credible for
a whole bunch of reasons the the
circumstances under which Sheeran
claimed to have flown in done the deed
and then left doesn't make any sense and
the involvement of Chuckie was basically
Sheeran copying the known fact that we
believe that the FBI believed and
basically every FBI agent that I spoke
to spoke to me on the record and said
that the Sheeran story was preposterous
your stepfather opened up to you but
only to the limited extent there are
some things he wouldn't tell you was
that frustrating to you and why wouldn't
he tell you the whole story it was not
frustrating to me at the end he believes
very much in the code of style and he
told me a lot of things but and he told
me certainly enough to believe for me to
understand the very difficult situation
he was in an office appeared and to
understand why he wasn't involved I
don't know what he didn't tell me I
don't think he knows exactly what
happened that afternoon but I think he
probably knows more than he told me
but in the end I respected his
commitments not to talk about it and he
didn't want to tell me and I came to
honor that commitment and Jack do you
have your own theory about who actually
did kill Hoffa I don't I mean I I really
don't have any idea the you know I know
what the FBI thinks but I have no way of
assessing it and frankly I don't think
we're ever gonna find out even if the
FBI even if it's true as the FBI
believes me
even if they know who did it I don't
think they know how it happened I don't
think they know what happened to off his
body
there was a gig the latest of a dozen
fruitless digs in 19 2013
oh I don't believe we're ever going to
solve the case in the sense of knowing
exactly what happened that afternoon
it's really an extraordinary mystery all
right professor Jack Goldsmith police
stay with us after break we'll be joined
by the reporter you called the Dean of
Hoffa reporting dan moldea as we
continue to dig deep into the mystery of
what happened to Jimmy Hoffa
we're back with more on the mystery of
what happened to Jimmy Hoffa with
fascinating insights in a new book by
Harvard Law Professor jack goldsmith in
the shadow of Hoffa whose own stepfather
Chuckie O'Brien was actually one of the
key suspects in the disappearance we're
also joined by dan moldea
who professor goldsmith calls the Dean
of journalists who have covered the
Hoffa case since he went missing in July
of 1975 dan thanks for joining us it's
been 34 years now what did you learn
from Jack Goldsmith book I thought Jack
wrote a wonderful book I I'm a big
supporter of it I gave her the great
blurb and I think that more than being a
true crime book it's a it's it's just a
great story I with all due respect to
Jack I've always viewed chuckle Brian is
being kind of a knuckle-dragger and the
idea of Jack Goldsmith admiring this
band as he grew up and and becoming this
great respected law professor at Harvard
the last I think it's just just a
wonderful story let me add Jack I
thought it's very touching how you
embraced Chuckie as a youth and then he
went to school and you came out as a
lawyer and you sort of distance yourself
from him and then you came back together
that was very emotional it was emotional
for me and it was a long journey I
basically cut him out of my life for 20
years and decided that that was the
wrong thing to do I fought his
forgiveness and he forgave me and we
grew very very close after that and
download a do you accept the Chuckie
O'Brien was not the person responsible
for luring Jimmy Hoffa to his killers I
do I in my book that came out 41 years
ago The Hoff Awards when I was 28 years
old I had the government had told me you
know chuckle Brian was driving the car
so I say according to government sources
chuckle Brian was driving the car in Act
one of the Hoffman burdur Act one of
three acts Act one pickup Act two the
delivery to the venue to the place of
his murder the scene of the crime and
then Act three the disposal of the body
I was told by
other bullet Moscato that IDO Giacalone
II was the person who was driving the
car he told me that Salva gulia was the
person who killed Jimmy Hoffa and he
told me that the body was brought back
to New Jersey where it was buried you
know in a landfill that he owned in
Jersey City you believe that he was
buried in New Jersey although the FBI
searched there never found him well that
was like a 57 acre site filled with
toxic waste rats
wild dogs and quicksand and it was a
tough area to search it was also in
December when they were searching it
when it was pretty cold and they gave up
that search fairly quickly and that was
saw the footage service search that was
in Detroit there but a number of
searches Jack Goldsmith do you accept
the theory he ended up in New Jersey
his body is at least I don't have any
basis for denying it but I don't have
any basis for attempting it either I'm
sure I know that Dan's telling the truth
but I don't think you don't have there's
no evidence he he was he just basing
that on something the brother Muscato
had told him and I just I don't I
haven't seen any direct evidence I don't
think anybody had about what happened
here we've got lots of informant
information saying lots of different
things again I mean Dan is the most
respected person in Barbie's sorry this
case is Ralph Picard oh he says Oh Hoffa
was murdered he was stuffed into a
55-gallon drum he was loaded onto a
gateway transportation truck and shipped
back to New Jersey and he was told this
information allegedly by steveandjenna
who was under the alleged
co-conspirators in the case during a
prison visitation a few days after
office murder is it fair to say both of
you would agree this case is not going
to be solved in our lifetimes I'm ever
optimistic I think it's going to solve
that I think people like Jack and me and
you Brian who were there I think you and
I were both there at the beginning I
think that III think the body's gonna be
found and I think the case is gonna be
saw Jack quickly all right well
professor Jack Goldsmith and dan moldea
thank you so much
for joining us tonight true crime meets
American history in a case that remains
one of the great unsolved mysteries and
both of you have written terrific books
I recommend them to our viewers highly
colored objects you bet
coming up next our shout out for the
brave reporter in Ukraine taking on all
comers
whether it's Moscow Washington or her
own government in Kiev when we return
and our shout out tonight is for a brave
journalist trying to cover the news and
hold officials accountable in a very
difficult place to do that Ukraine the
country is very much in the news with
the revelations about President Trump
asking for a favor from the Ukrainian
president but long before the world's
media began to focus on the country and
its corruption a small group of
journalists in Kiev had dedicated
themselves to bringing the truth to
Ukrainians including one young woman who
has put herself very much on the
frontlines nastiest acos career in
journalism has already seen her called a
hero
a traitor and a liar she's been on the
frontlines of war been threatened with
death been held hostage confronted both
Moscow and her own government in Kiev
all of that at the age of 33 given all
the pressure and given the threats and
the danger hmm you still want to be a
journalist given everything because you
know when you live in such country as
Ukraine it's always you you're always
you know have this feeling that it's not
boring it's can't be boring now the
deputy editor-in-chief of the Ukraine
television station she helped to found
Stano says she chose journalism as a
teenager after seeing reports of a
television cameraman for Reuters killed
in Iraq by US forces which claimed his
camera looked like a weapon it was 2003
yes I remember and I saw it's very
important to be such an dangerous places
and say the people choose from such
dangerous place and places and I said I
want to be journalist and
did not have to travel far to find a war
to cover it came to her when Russian
back forces turned parts of Ukraine into
a war zone hot spot five years ago and
then she was taken hostage by the
Russian back forces they took me to this
basement with something in my hat I mean
it's to us like some coat because that I
shouldn't see nothing where are we going
and of course they said that maybe they
will cut my hat like this when Nastya
was released after a few days she was
hailed as a hero for her courage under
such trying circumstances but then a few
years later when she produced this
report documenting how Ukraine's own
security services have their own secret
prisons the same people who had called
her our hero now said she was a traitor
giving the Russians ammunition to
criticize the Ukrainian government it's
not ok because it's illegal and this
true can help Stanko and her reporting
team tracked down people who had been
held in the secret compounds who
identified key details of the cells
where they were held and some of the
people who served as their guards and
thence tackle confronted the top
officials who had earlier denied the
existence of any such secret prisons you
see this is ten people telling outright
lies to the international organization
because they were recruited by for
example the Russian Federation now with
Ukraine at the center of attempts in the
US Congress to impeach President Donald
Trump stucco has another big story on
her hands you know and it's very but
Sacco says it's no time to ease up even
as she faces new criticism that her
reporting will only weaken the Ukrainian
president and helped the Russia
this is house Tonko put it when she was
honored by the Committee to Protect
Journalists with their International
Press Freedom Award it's difficult to
walk when you are expected to choose
between majorities and professional
journalism standing here in front of my
colleagues from all around the world I
know this pressure is not something only
we Ukrainians feel it's pressure
experienced by anyone who chooses
journalism as their profession but I
also know that there are is no need to
choose honest journalism in the best
form of patriotism
so our shout out tonight for Nastya
Sacco and her colleagues in Ukraine for
showing all of us what good journalism
is all about something needed evermore
in both Kiev Washington and around the
world that's our program for tonight
thanks for joining us we'll see you back
here on the law on crime Network next
week